foreign
[Music]
the game was always my dream to play at
the highest level to achieve greatness
too small not strong enough won't make
it you have to believe in yourself when
others don't hard work dedication and
commitment helped me to get to this
stage to represent my country at the
biggest tournament in the world
[Music]
huge for me I've always wanted
up and after not doing so last time
around this was the moment that really I
was most proud of
this world government is going to mean
to people what it's going to mean to
myself and my team which is everything
and
and I want to be a big leader on the
national team that's what I push for and
every time I step out on the field
that's that's what I want my my
teammates to see
we never expected any of this to to
happen I
the level he is where he is right now
but my wife and I knew there was
something in them playing soccer it was
the most unbearable to see how driven he
was I think I've just learned to be
Fearless ever since I was you know super
young playing against older kids you
know my dad taught me well Tommy's never
be scared of anyone go in be confident
be yourself put in the work I think you
can accomplish anything and that's the
way I've always seen it
ready yeah man yeah let's do this thing
are you ready
oh
[Music]
you got to do better than that I was
going for the bank shot ready off the
backboard
that's what I like to see how do you
keep that yeah that's how to keep
through all these like rough games it's
a competitive Spirit within me I just
always want to win no matter what it is
that I'm doing a lot of the top athletes
will have that same Drive in them when
something that they're doing isn't up to
their standards they're not going to
stop training not going to stop until
they get it right and that's how I've
always been I truly am competitive in
everything that I do whether it's this
golf soccer anything in the world did he
have a mindset of an elite soccer player
from a young age I believe he did I
think it's the fearlessness to want to
be put in uncomfortable positions and he
was Fearless when he was 15 years old
and he had to make a trip to Germany and
then on his next move to make a step
into the Premier League he accepted that
challenge you know you have to always
want to be the best in it in everything
you do whether it's every training
session whatever you're working on as
far as what you need in your game and
putting that extra time in and he's
willing to do that
started becoming a big fan of Chess and
you're I know that you stream chess I
love chess it started a couple years ago
I think there is a lot of just keeping
your mind sharp and the way that you
have to think quickly I also play a lot
of like speed chess like three minute
games where it's just like constantly
having to make decisions in some ways it
does like calm me down after a tough day
after a good day I can just come home
and
go play some chess and it's uh just
something that I always enjoy doing
what would your advice be to be a young
player here coping with the mental
pressures make sure you're always
enjoying the game because that's that's
been a real big one for me you know the
second that you feel like the game isn't
fun anymore and you're just playing just
to play and to please other people
you're never going to reach the highest
level so you need to be yourself enjoy
the game play because love it because
you have a passion for it and that's
what I feel like I'm at my best
[Music]